soirée de gala au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines plus de 120
ans leur venue de huis clos france
indoor andrésy se sont produits à
l'occasion de la troisième édition de la
soirée des champions ce mercredi soir
le niveau était relevé on a des
finalistes uniquement des finalistes du
championnat de france nationale 1 et
nationales à élite dans toutes les
catégories quasiment que ce soit en solo
audio ou équipe on a également des
membres du team france a qui sont là on
a des éléments qui sont sélectionnés
pour la coupe d'europe en france au mois
de juillet et surtout on a quelques
athlètes qui sont et champion de france
est sélectionné pour les championnats du
monde au mois d'août en suède qui sont
là ce soir et qui nous font l'honneur de
nous montrer leurs prestations et de la
partager avec des démonstrations duo ou
en solo ou en équipe était programmé
pendant deux heures l'objectif de cette
soirée était de propulser le jogging
dans une autre sphère médiatique pour
toucher un large public dans les gradins
on recensait plus de 700 spectateurs
c'est important parce que ça n'est que
la troisième édition est en fait quelque
part c'est le tranquille le trempant
dont on compte se servir pour sortir du
public juste toi ligne mais pour attirer
à et des sponsors comme peut en avoir ce
soir mais surtout du pli biteau
extérieur c'est pour ça qu'on a fait un
format court de deux heures un soir de
semaine on est parisien on a l'habitude
de sortir
l'entrée ne coûte pas cher on espère sur
le long terme attirer des gens à tirer
des médias et faire de plus en plus
connaître autour d'une batte ombre une
nouvelle soirée de gala pourrait être
organisée l'année prochaine au vélodrome
nationale les yvelines sur les
départements avec le plus de licenciés
en france avec six ans tout à l'heure
inscrit pour la saison 2015 2016